a new labor department report says
inflation rose by almost 7 percent in
the last year the highest one-year
increase
in 39 years
president biden says the increase has
peaked and that prices should begin to
fall sooner than expected but mr biden
acknowledged americans are feeling the
pinch in their wallets christina raffini
is at the white house with the latest on
this christina good morning
good morning jeff well the good news is
holiday cheer is free the problem is
almost everything else is going to cost
you
if you look at what what what's
inflation all about for people
they're paying more for things they need
than they had to pay before at the
conclusion of an international summit
president biden addressed a pressing
domestic issue when you walk in the
grocery store and you're paying more for
whatever you're purchasing it matters it
matters to people americans are seeing
the worst inflation in nearly four
decades including food for end of the
year festivities from roast beef up more
than 26 percent to chicken and seafood
up nearly 11 percent
some shoppers are taking it in stride
it is what it is
we need some celebration in our life at
this point while others are scouring
sales i'm going to look for bargains but
definitely price hunt i'm probably doing
a lot more of that this year a new poll
found more than half of americans say
inflation is causing the major or minor
financial strain much of it caused by
pandemic related supply chain problems
the cost of shipping a container between
asia and the west coast is more than 25
percent lower than it was three months
ago the white house says it's done what
it can to address supply chain issues
and the price of some things including
gas is already declining we've seen a
decrease in costs in some of the areas
that account for a big percentage of the
rise in inflation
the white house says that passage of the
president's buildback better plan would
help americans feeling the squeeze pay
less for other items including child
care but that measure has yet to get a
vote in the
senate christina rafini force at the
white house thank you